let's bring in republican congressman
tony gonzalez he represents the largest
border district in texas stretching over
800 miles of the border
congressman good to be with you there's
a lot of criticism of the vice president
for going to el paso instead of going to
the mcallen hidalgo area in the heart of
the rio grande valley sector the vice
president's office said
that of el paso it represents larger
border dynamics and it is a critical
critical part of understanding the human
experience of migration but take a look
at these numbers
the rio grande valley the year today two
hundred and nineteen
thousand seven hundred and eighty eight
border encounters versus el paso
eighty five thousand two hundred and
seventy three what's the difference
between what the vice president would
see in the rio grande valley sector as
opposed to what she's seeing today in el
paso
yeah the the border is very different
throughout you know i represent over 40
percent of the border and it's just very
diverse
you know kamala's first visit to the
border as vice president
has been a huge flop you know she's just
kind of parachuted in
uh only listen to folks for only a few
hours that's not how you
listen to folks and that's not how you
respond to it what's happening in el
paso is much different than what's
happening in the del rio sector
or in the big bend sector or laredo or
rio grande valley
i'll give you an example they're saying
they're making progress well in
culberson county just very close to el
paso
there was there was a 35 year old man
traveling with his 15 year old son
from ecuador they make the trek well
guess what his 15 year old son
dies because they got separated from a
group he died a horrible death uh
you know not having any water that's
that's the reality
of what's happening on the ground
migrants are dying yeah yeah i mean
there's no question about that and as
the heat continues to build
as well uh it gets more and more
dangerous and even chad wolfe was saying
that he doesn't expect there to be the
typical
decline in migration during the hot
summer months but
i just wanted to point out because we we
do like to be fair and balanced here
at fox news she is getting she kamil
harris is getting a lot of criticism for
going to el paso
but back in march a congressional
delegation led by the house minority
leader kevin mccarthy
went to el paso here's what he said
during that visit
i came down here because i heard of the
crisis it's more than a crisis
this is a human heartbreak the sad part
about all this
it didn't have to happen this crisis
is created by the presidential policies
of this new administration
so he was very critical of the
administration but nobody criticized him
for going to el paso saying oh you
missed the big story in the rio grande
valley sector so why is the vice
president coming in for so much
criticism for doing the same thing
you know i was on that visit with kevin
mccarthy back in march
and what we saw in el paso then were
record numbers
that processing center where she visited
today
it was beyond at capacity now i've also
visited that same processing center
since then and the numbers have gone
down in the el paso county
in the el paso uh sector but there's
other sectors that have
the numbers have only increased del rio
and rio grande valley in particular
so what i get at is this border crisis
is always shifting
and always moving you can't just land
somewhere
talk to somebody for a few hours and
then become an expert
you really have to dedicate the time and
effort from all of it from el paso to
del rio to eagle
uh to the the rio grande valley little
radio sector
all of it is important i hope this is
the first of many visits
that she makes to really tackle this
problem you know something really
popped out at me when the vice
president's delegation landed
there in el paso congresswoman veronica
escobar
said to the press pool that was
assembled there welcome to the new
ellis island making comparisons between
el paso
and the millions of people who came
through ellis island
in a wave of immigration to the united
states in the early 20th century
what did you make of that comment
there's a big difference
look we're a nation of immigrants we are
also a nation of laws
and our laws must be followed
what i make out of it is we need to
reform
our legal immigration process at the
same time
we have to uphold our laws people don't
feel
safe encouraging folks to make this trek
illegally
is wrong we need to reform our legal
immigration system
welcome those who want to come live the
american dream but do it through a legal
fashion
when we start encouraging folks to come
over illegally
which is exactly what this
administration has done
that is the wrong approach that that uh
unravels
america we stand for law and order
congressman tony gonzalez good to have
you with us today to kick off our
coverage and again we're expecting to
hear from the vice president coming up
in the next half hour so appreciate your
time hope you have a good weekend thank
you
thank you sir